it from tta adventist ascent association they act
a remnant religion or remnant people so i guess
is the is there a remnant religion or is it just a
remnant people both there's a remnant religion why
revelation 12 17 and the dragon was wrath with
the woman and went to make what was the remnant
of a seed which keep the commandments of god
and have the testimony of jesus those are the
fundamental elements of the religion of course
it's not religion that saves us it is jesus christ
but christ started the church on the earth with
the twelve disciples the israelites and the
wilderness were called a church by stephen
in his great sermon in acts chapter seven
and so yes it's a church it's a religion it's
a people it's a people that practice a religion
and the religion is righteousness and the concise
expression of righteousness the ten commandments
and the living flesh and blood expression
of that is the life of christ which must be
reproduced in us so yes there's a remnant
people there's a remnant religion and the
religion stems all the way back from that
pure church which keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus christ
yes and the faith of jesus revelation 14 12.
amen amen thank you now cassandra james i'll make
this the last question she asked how excuse me
shall the people of god escape the prosecution if
they were to remain i think that means persecution
if they were to remain in the city since we were
admonished to leave since we were admonished to
leave sorry let me read that again am i set
up shall the people of god escape persecution
if they were if they were to remain in
the city since we were admonished to leave
the jews the christians in jerusalem between
1866 and 80 70 they would manage to leave when
god caused the romans to withdraw mysteriously for
them but god was under control the christians left
the city and moved to the hills in the mountains
not one perished if god sent us a message to his
servant leave the sins and we choose to stay
doesn't mean we'll be lost but we will suffer
unnecessarily so if she says leave leave when god
delivered lot from sodom lot tall god told him go
to the mountains he said let me go to zoa so don't
say okay go ahead he went to zoa then he finally
left for the the mountain eventually so god's way
was best for him if god says lead the cities leave
you make an individual decision to leave don't
leave if others are leaving leave because god
has convicted you because convicts us at different
times under different circumstances you've got to
make an individual decision mind character and
personality volume 2 page 4 23 paragraph two
the gospel deals with individuals and so if
you're convicted leave and if it's god's will
for you to leave he will make the way but if you
stay where god has told you to leave you open
yourself to unnecessary suffering i'm not saying
you'll be lost but you'll be saved painfully